good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday it is
hump day
so don't forget to help someone you love
speaking of someone i love i am joined
for the third consecutive day in a row
which is so sickening given the fact she
just gave birth it's jackie a morning
toast original recipe original recipe
hey guys happy to be here it's really
catching up with me like it's a little
too much too soon oh really but i'm
happy to do it this is such a big week
so i'm running on adrenaline running on
steamy skinny vibes running on end logs
you're running on steamy vibes i am
feeling quite steamy because it's always
warm in here it is always warm in here
we've got to fix it and we're always
wearing sweatshirts and leggings and air
force ones and twinning we're literally
doing something like clowns again this
is like embarrassing i know what's with
us i guess it's the air force ones i
know because like they're just such
great shoes you have to wear it with a
crew neck yeah and we're just always
wearing crew necks and i just have
decided like until
i'm where i want to be in life
physically mentally and emotionally it's
just going to be a sweatshirt from me i
don't care what month it is like i tried
the first time i came into the studio to
like put together an alpha because i was
like
so excited and i looked horrific and so
now i'll just be covering
everything until i'm ready to show you
guys more you're like literally gonna do
a full reveal in like six months
six months yeah um well we've got a
great show for you guys today today
it's wednesday
and um we've got deer toasters we also
have an update from someone who wrote in
about something particularly vile so
that'll be exciting jackie did not watch
the real housewives of new jersey finale
uh reunion part one because she has a
child
it's like hanging over my head all night
and i woke up in the middle of the night
to pump and i was like i could watch it
now but then i didn't want to wake my
mind up because i needed to go back to
sleep it's not worth it it was only part
one like it was part three maybe perhaps
but i was really excited to watch it and
i just didn't want to rush it like i
want to watch it when i want to watch it
it was really good and i have a lot of
thoughts i feel like it really and what
my main takeaway is we haven't even
spoken about this how it's been widely
reported i think it's like pretty much
true that jackie goldschneider was
demoted to friend of i just yes but how
can they make that call before the
reunion and why make that call before
the ring and like see how things play
out i feel like it's such a mistake and
after watching the reunion last night
i'm even more
like cemented in my belief that it's the
biggest mistake of all time especially
because if they don't want the show to
continue to be like everyone just
tiptoeing around theresa they've like
now changed the landscape and the
dynamics so much it's such a mistake
it's so wrong i'm like i'm actually
really furious about it and i never
thought i would feel that way because i
was a jackie goldschneider like hater up
until recently yeah and um i might be
caught from a different cloth but it's
top quality fabric which is always good
to know don't forget that don't forget
that so we are excited to be here we're
coming off our metgal extravaganza
which was very fun and exciting i know
we didn't get to all the looks like
there was still hundreds left but i feel
like we did what was needed we needed we
did the bulk of it yeah i don't recall
maybe there was like one or two after
where i was like [ __ ] we didn't mention
them but there are so many people so
many and we did what we had to do and
that's what we're gonna do here today at
the morning toast this is our final
episode of the week because for anyone
who doesn't know tomorrow's like a
really big day um i'm performing at
madison square garden tickets available
at girl with no job.com tour it's gonna
be fabulous
and
i'm also doing a show tonight oh my god
i keep forgetting about that um a little
warm-up show chelsea music hall it's
gonna be good it's gonna be good that's
gonna be fun like an intimate night with
girl with no job you know it's a
fireside chat
ooh look at you teddy roosevelt
elizabeth holmes fdr yeah is that what
she i don't know fireside chats always
remind me of like tech companies that
like spend money on these like you know
team outings and it's like let's go to a
cabin and do a fireside chat they were
always doing fireside chats and younger
yeah but you know it's fdr who started
that no i didn't know a little fun fact
with the advent of the radio he would do
a fireside chat and talk to the nation
wow you really learn so much when your
co-host is a historical friction freak
freak is that nice is that nice got out
of bed three days in a row [ __ ] it's
not nice it's not nice
um so what else what's going on with you
not much we recorded the redheads
yesterday always a great time with the
girls they're so funny the redness is
just like a hysterical podcast we should
be in the comedy section except we like
being in arts so we are higher always in
the top yeah yeah comedy is a really
competitive category it is like those
office ladies [ __ ] up like always if you
have a podcast find the most obscure
category that you can put it in so that
you have a chance at hitting number one
and that's also i'm so glad you brought
that up because when you see influencers
sorry this is like so shady and mean of
me like when you see influencers be like
yes like we're chopping chopping the
tarts
topping the charts new episode they're
like tricking you into thinking that
their podcast is popular but it's not
they're just in like a random obscure i
know that's really neat to say cuz like
our podcast is so big and i should
really be more humble but i won't
they're just tricking you into thinking
that their podcast is big when it's
actually not it's like easy to be the
biggest fish in a puddle
wow
shot day
coming out swinging i said what i said i
will say if your podcast is number one
in any category like it's not teen tiny
yeah but it's not you know number one
it's not joe rogan call her daddy you're
not it's not conan you're not joe rogan
you're not conan redheads used to be in
society and culture but it was just like
a little too depressing so then we moved
over to arts oh that's better now yeah
society and culture is like probably
fourth or fifth most competitive so what
do you think it goes by i think it goes
i'll tell you because apple sorts it
that's my theory they have the i think
it's news and then comedy it's news and
then comedy and then perhaps sports but
the way you can um
the pull down is not alphabetical or
anything which leads me to believe that
it is
chronological like that feature isn't
even there right now hold on hold on yes
it is i looked at it yesterday i'm
always checking the charts
on the top right where you scored by it
wasn't coming up oh you know what and i
got a new phone so maybe
man my poc okay all categories here we
go first news second comedy third
society and culture wow moving on up i
feel like because everybody puts their
podcast in society and culture because
it's a very big umbrella right fourth
business biz news fifth true crime
that's interesting we're literally sixth
in comedy right now sixth sports so
we're six in number two that's pretty
good we're six and number two and then
health and fitness religion and
spirituality arts education maybe we
should move to education seems less
competitive no history i gotta start a
history podcast i'll be number one every
week tv and film that's actually that's
surprising that it's so low yeah a lot
of people throw theirs in tv and film we
do tv recaps we could be number one in
tv and film let's move over i'm so sick
of conan and the office ladies totally
and heather mcdonald she's always in
front of us science we could do a show
about elon musk number one every week
technology music kids and family leisure
that's a nice that's a good i mean i
feel very at peace when listening to the
morning toast i do think we would
qualify for leisure
that's really interesting then fiction
and then government woof woof yeah
no one's listening to government
podcasts i'm shocked
um speaking of government we have an
amazing show today um
anything else you want to catch up on
before we dive right in yeah oh one
thing that i actually wanted to catch up
on that's not a story but i feel like i
would be remiss devastated and
heartbroken if i didn't mention it was
jessica simpson's instagram stories
yesterday yes she had a birthday party
for her daughter and you know we heard
rumors that her and north were friends
with her daughter but we didn't really
have proof now we have proof they had
like kids are obsessed with these squish
mellows do you know them no they're like
these stuff you're gonna know
squishmallows they're like collectible
stuffed animals or whatever um so i
think her daughter had i don't know if
it was her birthday but north bought her
a present so it looked like it might
have been her birthday um they had like
this movie night squishmallow birthday
party and not only was north there and
she brought her a gift that was a pair
of sneakers and jessica was posting
pictures of them penelope was there too
i saw the pictures so cute i think the
kid just had a birthday party because
that's how we learned that they're
friends and that kim wasn't at the party
so maybe this was just like a movie
night in the backyard in a pickup truck
cause like that's what celebrity kids do
it was so cute sounds like an ideal
night for me like an adult yeah laying
in the back of a truck watching a movie
on a calabasas cliff
you're living the wrong life sister 100
like the fact that i wasn't born
jessica simpson or nicole
nicole oh my god
the fact that i wasn't born jessica
simpson's daughter like is my cross
swear yeah there was a mistake and there
was a glitch in the matrix there was a
glimpse
i'm done like i'm really [ __ ] done i
can't even talk today you are chopping
the tarts though i'm chopping the tarts
and the tarts are chopping me a hundred
percent i need to i need to get like my
brain and my mouth more connected
because i have a show tonight like i
need to
start focusing on the words in which i
speak but that's good make the mistakes
now
okay i think we should get right in
because we have some great stories to
chat about we have dear toasters and we
have claudia is going to talk a little
new jersey so without further ado
do do it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
jenny kane
we're updating our homes for spring and
we're investing in quality pieces that
are making our rooms feel and look
complete
jenny kane has everything you need to
create the home of your dreams from
handmade furniture and kitchen
essentials to pillows and throws that
you can pair with anything their
handcrafted textiles come in versatile
cotton and linen which is perfect for
the sofa the bedroom or an accented
accented edition you can settle in with
the epitome of cozy comfort the tahoe
cashmere throw and the alpaca bake
basket weave throw they also perfect
dinnerware and serve wear it's durable
hardworking and it starts at just 25
these tabletop prices are made pieces
are made for all types of entertaining
they also have candles and slippers
their slippers are some of my favorite
and the candles smell amazing they last
really long and they really like smell
up your home in a nice way
the scents are inspired by california
and they're hand poured in los angeles
and the slippers are coming shearling
they come in suede they are the ultimate
indoor indulgence treat yourself you
know
you deserve it spend some time
taking care of you
jenny kane home creates california
inspired classics for any room or mood
they're grounded in natural textures
inviting neutrals and they are pieces
you'll love coming home to also check
out the jenny kane ranch the latest
full-scale interior project in santa
enas that brings the california
aesthetic to life the remarkable space
will
that was a full gut
renovation and you can follow jenny kane
at jenny kane or jenny kane home at
jenny cain home on instagram or head to
their blog rip and tan for all the
details get 20 off all furniture and
home decor plus early product access and
much more with the jkh membership at
jennykaine.commembership or go to
jennycane.comhome
to create the space you'll never want to
leave that's jennycaine.com
home j j-e-n-n-i k-a-y-n-e dot com slash
home i just got a delicious jenny kane
blanket that harold and i are loving
yeah
so cozy
okay first story big crazy news of the
day dave chappelle was attacked on stage
at hollywood bowl by an audience member
with armed with a weapon
so last night at the hollywood bowl they
were filming netflix is a joke and
dave chappelle was doing his set towards
the end of the set around 10 45
shocking footage footage shows chappelle
standing on stage as an audience member
charged and slammed him to the floor
seconds later the attacker was tackled
by security and then he was beat up
thoroughly by a bunch of the people
backstage uh the man who lives in los
angeles was arrested for felony assault
with a deadly weapon he was armed with a
knife and carrying a replica handgun
with a blade inside he was taken to the
hospital before he was booked early
wednesday into jail on 30 000 bail i
have so many thoughts my first thought
is like i really feel bad for dave
chappelle there's nothing scarier
than being tackled especially like when
you're just like such a target just
standing there under a bright light and
everyone else is sitting in darkness um
i also feel bad for will smith because
in one way or the other this is his
fault and everyone's gonna figure
everyone's like saying that already so i
know that wasn't his intention when he
slapped chris smith chris smith i'm not
okay
when he slapped chris rock i know that
wasn't his intention but via the
butterfly effect here we are
and i'd also like to say i don't
understand how this happened because the
hollywood bowl is like a really legit
venue and you're telling me through all
the security we all have to put up with
that a man with a replica gun got into
knife but the knife was inside the gun
so like you're telling me like when you
walk through that metal detector or like
nothing went off
like the knife is made of metal if the
replica was not made of metal then maybe
it wouldn't have set it off but the wire
replicates our tings they're going
through my tampons i can't bring an
advil into a club right but a replica
gun and a knife a okay this is like a
huge oversight on the behalf of the
hollywood bowl like
security you can't even like have your
phone at a comedy show i know and i hate
to blame anyone other than the person
who stormed the stage but a lot of a
series of events had to occur in order
for this man to get into the venue with
his items and be seated close to dave
chappelle and so while it is this man's
fault 100
um i'm just so curious how something
like this happens in this day and age
like okay you can't stop someone from
storming a stage like we all are
human beings with independence but you
can stop someone from bringing a knife
yeah and they didn't you would hope
right maybe you can't
so this is so this is awful like this is
really really awful i saw the video
looks like dave chappelle's totally fine
physically
um which is good and everyone was able
to you know laugh it off right after the
tackle chris rock came on stage and gave
dave chappelle a hug and asked was that
will smith
then um dave chappelle carried on and
made some jokes he was about to announce
a musical act
and so you know everyone i think was
able to carry on because he was done
with mostly done with his set which
right to bounce back and have to
continue performing is literally sounds
horrible right
so
i think they made it okay it'll be
unclear if it's going to be in the
special i don't know what they even
should do about that what we were
talking about in general this is just
like setting a jarring worry some
precedent for like comedians being fair
game for verbal and physical assault
right um but we were talking before the
show about like whether so they're
filming netflix is a joke is a comedy
festival that netflix is putting on and
of course they're filming a lot of the
talent to make content for netflix
comedy specials um so i'm sure that this
whole evening was filmed i'm sure that
they have the incident on camera and we
were going back and forth as to whether
netflix should put this in or not like
part of me
actually i want to say no
completely because then this guy becomes
a celebrity and then other people are
going to be like wow if i want to get on
netflix all i have to do is tackle a
celebrity and i think it like encourages
bad behavior yeah even though part of me
was also thinking like we
it's like such a horrible thing i don't
know i don't know i'm i i'm like what
really happened so maybe you should just
put it in plus i think after you know
when everybody i think it was like
chappelle's crew and his personal
security and i think was about like 20
people who beat up on this guy and it
was definitely a very big reaction but
[ __ ] around and find out you don't get
to charge someone with a knife and then
say that the reaction is too big
afterwards right no that's a hundred
percent true but i imagine that like
perhaps dave chappelle doesn't want it
on television
his entourage like it looks bad 20 to
one but you only don't see the one guy
who stormed the stage with a knife right
um so this is just like terrible it's
really [ __ ] scary and terrible
and it's just crazy that it happens to
dave chappelle who's
the biggest comedian in the world he has
you know
swarms of security
um he's in a in an environment it's like
a legit venue right it's sponsored by
netflix like you would think that
something like this couldn't happen at
an event like this to a person like this
but here it is happening right and even
with like the logistics of like the
stage being you know some stages you
couldn't really jump right they're too
high they're too far
still at the hollywood bowl it could be
done it's so scary and honestly
i'm sure he's fine
but i hope he's fine oh i think it
rattles any everyone i mean
not to make literally everything about
me but like
when you're on stage and you hear a
weird sound like it is so scary but you
have to keep going because most of the
time it's just like a sound it's not
someone storming the stage so like your
heart stops but then you have to keep
going because people are like what's
wrong with this [ __ ] yeah so for that
to actually be something real is so
scary like
it's every person human beings not even
comedians it's every human being's worst
nightmare like
being attacked for no reason yeah
lose their energy like
oh this goes beyond and this guy got his
ass handed to him which is exactly what
he deserved i'm sorry there were photos
after of him on the stretcher and his
elbows dislocated from his arm it's
gross it's really gross but [ __ ] around
and find out and that's the moral of the
story that's the moral of everything i
was just gonna say that it is the moral
of every story yep
so we'll see what happens if dave
responds what will what will come of
this dave only responds to things like
in comedy format like he's not gonna
release a statement right and this is
also like really chris rock's first time
speaking out about the will smith thing
right really because how crazy that well
smith that
chris rock was there right
no just so weird yeah it's not okay like
we are not okay no as a society we are
unwell unwell and this has got to stop
if you come to my show just saying and
you get on stage and like you try to
touch me like uh what happens after that
is on you like i will literally i'm a
big [ __ ] like you do not want to [ __ ]
with me like i'm strong no and she's got
a lot of people in her corner no and
like you don't want to mess with me to
make the show that you do want to mess
with me but you don't no and like okay i
like that like his team escorted him off
stage but like if you're gonna come out
and try and embarrass me like i'm
leaving you on stage and i'm beating you
up in front of everyone like you don't
get the privacy of back of backstage
it's a public flogging all the cameras
coming out for a public affair and i'll
tell everyone to get their phones out
wow okay there we go
but then like the toasters are
civilized so they are i don't know
toaster after a couple of spritz she'd
get wild true that
are you ready for our next story
yeah a little more controversy lily
reinhardt is slamming quote starving kim
kardashian over her met gala 2022 diet
yes as we reported yesterday kim shared
that she lost 16 pounds in three weeks
to fit into the maryland dress and that
did not sit well with lily reinhardt who
took to her instagram story on tuesday
and wrote in text to walk on a red
carpet and do an interview where you say
how starving you are because you haven't
eaten a carb in the last month all to
fit into a [ __ ] dress so wrong so
[ __ ] on hundreds of levels the star
who did not call out kim by name added
that it's disgusting for celebrities to
admit to starving themselves considering
how many people idolize them
she said quote to openly admit to
starving yourself for the sake of the
met gala when you know very well that
millions of young men and women are
looking up to you and listening to your
every word the ignorance is otherworldly
disgusting
okay i have so many thoughts on this i
guess this is that backlash you were
talking about i really hadn't seen any
but now i now i'm familiar and she
doesn't say kim by name but she might as
well have she wasn't talking about
anyone else other than kim no no no
which i just don't like to single out
kim because i watched all the interviews
and every venus williams was like
talking about how she's so hungry and
like how she and all these other girls
were like i can't breathe in my dress so
to single out kim for and blame her for
the entire culture which you perceive to
be toxic is unfair first of all
second of all i the way that kim framed
it in the sense of like this for her
this is a role and we've heard a million
stories mark wahlberg joaquin phoenix
jared leto like people always dropping
and gaining like 40 50 pounds in short
amount of times i don't see any backlash
there so like why is it it's just like
for me it's like whether the argument
about kim is valid or not it bothers me
that it's always kim it reminds me of
like when kendall came out with 8-1-8
people really upset because they thought
you know it's a mexican it's made in
mexico and it's a mexican drink and
there's totally an argument to be made
there but like why do these arguments
only come out for the kardashians like
nobody said anything about cosmic egos
is george clooney mexican nobody said
anything about um sorak is p diddy
russian like so it's like these whether
they're valid or not like the fact that
these conversations only happen around
the kardashians like it bothers me it
does yeah it bothers me as well and i
agree when kim says she's training for a
role you might not like that her role is
considered you know just the
night a fashions night out but this is
perhaps one of the most iconic things
that kim has ever done i took no issue
with
her sharing because by the way she did
and also she didn't lose 16 pounds
because she wants to be skinny she had
to fit into a dress it wasn't like you
know i need to be this weight so i can
look good at the mac gala she needed to
be a certain weight so that she could
fit in the dress right and i personally
as a person my
the way that i feel is i would rather
someone like shed shred for the wed
and let us know what they did and that
it was really [ __ ] hard and not just
like oh i just happened to fit into
marilyn monroe's [ __ ] dress i agree i
think that when celebrities pop up on
red carpets looking insanely stunning
like i just had a burger at the hotel i
think that contributes more to like
toxic body images you're like why don't
i look like that yeah because i just had
a burger and i can't fit my ass in my
jeans whereas i know why i don't look
like this because i have eaten carbs for
three weeks straight i wasn't doing two
a days yeah tomatoes i agree so like
don't get me wrong i mean in celebrity
culture there's so much toxicity when it
comes to body image and weight and it's
hella problematic but i prefer someone
to be completely transparent with me
than just showing up looking like sheer
perfection leaving me wondering like
well if she's just a regular girl how
did that happen there must be something
wrong with me right no actually i know
there's nothing wrong with me now thanks
to kim because i eat whatever i want
whenever i want because you're not
putting in that word right so i don't
know i just there's so many about things
and maybe it's just because i'm a chem
apologist like if this was someone else
maybe i would feel differently but i
really don't think so i don't get
bothered um when people talk about their
journey i really don't that's just me
um
i'm
i look the way that i am
i look the way that i do because of
decisions i make
and i guess came in for kim kim is
extremely influential but
i don't know i think this is a stretch i
do but i know a lot of people don't
agree with me even in the comments
yesterday on youtube people um
people are like furious at kim so like
you do you i'm i'm not furious i think i
would feel the same way about the
premise of the argument if it were any
other celebrity but i'm just more
invested because it's kim yes lily
reinhardt was beefing with someone that
i'm not like obsessed with i i don't
really know if i would think too hard
about it yeah and i mean i think for kim
like she's been doing this her entire
career like letting us know when she's
losing weight gaining posting her uh
workouts letting us know when she's on a
diet when she's having beignets in new
orleans like and i'm she's gotten
backlash all all along but i think for
her like she
doesn't care because
like on principle she doesn't have an
issue with it it's not like oh oops i'm
sorry i didn't know that i that i yeah
did that you know yeah
no i'm just there's there's like a few
things about this that i just also don't
like singling out like culture
the the issue in celebrity and in
hollywood with body image and weight is
so big and it's not kim kardashian's
fault i'm sorry it's not so to like
center the whole argument on kim i think
is really unfair
yeah
and just everybody has different
experiences and everybody like
feels differently about what what
they're seeing whether you know you're
someone like lily reinhardt who this is
upsetting to you but you could have be
someone with lily reinhardt's same
experience and see this and not find it
upsetting right right or like triggering
right yeah i just i'm not agreeing with
lily reinhardt on this um
like at all no me neither but i do a lot
of people do so yeah
there you go there you go our next story
little exciting fatherhood news
news exciting fatherhood news
post malone is expecting his first child
with longtime girlfriend who knew he had
a long time girlfriend not i
post malone said i'm excited for this
next chapter in my life i'm the happiest
i've ever been and for since i could
remember i was sad he told tmz time to
take care of my body and my family and
my friends and spread as much love as we
can every day that's so gorgeous sources
close to page six said the couple hosted
a private party with friends and family
in southern california over the weekend
to celebrate the exciting news that is
just like so traditional so sweet i had
no idea he had a girlfriend um love this
i love to see posts i'm so sorry what
i'm so sorry
so the article said source is close to
post so i just it's page six so i assume
this is the new york post oh no source
is close to post as in malone yeah yeah
no of course that is so funny that is
very confusing though i feel that um i
love this for him i feel like you know
posties growing up i feel like hearts
are breaking
everywhere he should be so my heart goes
out to all the girls who thought that
this would be them and it turned out
that it wasn't you um i see you i hear
you and i'm here for you did you know
that he had a long-term girlfriend no
clue no clue no that he was just like
this family man no i love that the thing
about post malone is like you think you
know him but you don't right and like he
lives in utah he loves country music
he's very unplugged he loves guitar he
has his priorities in order no it's
actually so true like especially for how
famous he is he could be like anything
he wanted living in the biggest house in
beverly hills but you're right he's like
a weirdly traditional
rural king right like having like a
little gender reveal party it's so
chilly
it's chewy post malone is chewgate post
malone chugalicious
he should make his own remix chew
delicious toast
chugalicious makes the girls go loco
um love that for him
beautiful really beautiful
beautiful happy for him know that i am
well we've been getting a lot of hate
comments about our singing i saw like is
this your guy's first time watching has
something changed nothing like i i
i just can't believe like if you or like
someone close to me had a voice that was
like as good as mine i would make them
sing for me all the time and i'm giving
it away for free yeah and there's always
a reason behind the song like we
integrated into
the stories because we got our reasons
just like you
when you okay we'll stop but like no but
it's really upsetting it's just a little
random considering we've been doing this
for five years that we always have a
song in our heart you know what it is
i think this little instrument like has
definitely increased it's simple math
when this enters the equation
we have to sing more you know yeah
give us a song any song
honey time we gonna have a good time a
thousand hands up to the sky we gonna
get toasted tonight
can't let it fade
we got a sparkle in our eye can't let it
wait
i'm counting down until we start we're
renegades
we come to play
and we play hard
two three four
hundred time we gonna have a good time a
thousand hands up to the sky we gonna
get toasted tonight
should i keep going no
wow
have been feeling no kidding
um
yeah i think as long as there's like a
cap of 10 to 20 seconds on the song i
don't know why you guys are complaining
it's like yeah and also like just notice
the gift in front of you and be grateful
don't be ungrateful okay don't be don't
be all ungrateful are you ready for our
next story only if it's the next story
that's brought to you by caraway's
non-toxic products love caraway and
they're non-toxic products it is time to
ditch the chemicals with caraway homes
non-toxic cookware and bakeware
collections so you can make healthier
cooking a piece of cake caraway homes
non-toxic kitchenware are all designed
for the modern home and they feature a
chemical-free ceramic coating so food
can be prepared with peace of mind that
no hard to pronounce compound will leach
into your healthy ingredients all their
sets come equipped with easy to access
storage solutions so that there's no
stacking required if you've got a drawer
full of crap then you know how important
that is
their cookware set is a modern chemical
free iteration of the traditional 16
piece set but it's boiled down to just
the four essentials which is a fry pan a
saute pan saucepan and a dutch oven and
they also have the bakeware set which is
an assortment of non-toxic baking
essentials that every modern kitchen
needs so you can get baking goods
without any of the bads so again it's
non-toxic it's eco-friendly they're easy
cooking with the ceramic naturally slick
surface that means nothing sticks and
it's well loved they have over 25 000
rave reviews including us we have a lot
of the products visit caraway home.com
tmt to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 10 off your next purchase
this deal is exclusive for our listeners
so visit caraway home slash tmt as in
the morning toast tmt or just use code
tmt at check out caraway non-toxic
cookware made modern um the colors are
really cute i have the pink um cookware
set and it's very premium i have like
for years been plagued by drawers full
of crap and caraway home is just fixing
all my problems mismatched crap that
does stick no like you know you've hit a
low when you're using like a saucepan
with a cover that's like from a frying
pan yeah we've all been there rough just
swap it all out for caraway home slash
tmt okay our next story a little
security concerning security news an
intruder disguised as a priest spent the
night at the queen's windsor castle and
it wasn't me how the [ __ ] is this always
happening an intruder disguised as
disguised as a priest conned his way
inside windsor castle on april 26 and
even spent the night leaving just hours
before queen elizabeth made her return
home he said his name was father cruz
and claimed to be a friend of the
battalion's padre the reverend matt
coles he was invited in and offered
something to eat in the officer's mess a
source told britain's talk tv the source
explained that within a few hours the
man was drinking with officers in the
bar and started telling stories about
his life including that he had served in
iraq he was telling lots of tall tales
and the lads were enjoying his banter
and having a few drinks it was only
later when he started talking about how
he had worked as an injector seat test
pilot and had some organs replaced that
the chaps started to get suspicious
security apparently did not conduct any
further investigations into the man and
authorities were not alerted until the
next morning just three hours before
queenie returned to windsor castle from
her 96th birthday party at sandringham
oh my god how long she was iconic yeah
the thing is like not only is this so
abhorrent
to you know
intrude into a personal a person's home
but to do so as a man of god just takes
a cloth this takes it to another more
disgusting
repulsive
level i mean yes though i do
can understand the urge to like get
close to the queen and just like want to
be you don't think we all feel that way
right and want to be in her space but
this is unacceptable and this has
happened before in the past we saw in
the crown and you would think like
what's the um the queen's peeps called
like
her ladies and waiting no no no those
aren't don't exist anymore like
scotland yards thank you myself
scotland yards should be on top of this
thank you myself
you sounded like dana
only only true sorry this is gonna be an
extremely hot take only true [ __ ]
freaks talk to themselves
okay that's just a hot tape well i had a
dream last night that i was talking to
myself that i was like looking in the
mirror
and i was like thinking that i was
seeing
i was talking to someone else
and then i realized i was talking to
myself i was like oh it's gotten crazy
um one time
ben like okay one time my friend jenna
was like i just ran into ben on the
street she texted me i'm like oh my
that's so funny she's like yeah he was
literally like mumbling and talking to
himself
and i was like what
she was like yeah it was like kind of
weird and then i told ben i'm like when
you saw jenna like what were you doing
and he was like nothing i'm like she
says you were talking to yourself he's
like no i wasn't i think he might have
been like going through something
because he was literally like wandering
around the streets like mumbling that's
so weird like i talk to myself all the
time but my lips don't move no that's
called thinking
we all do that
your lips don't move that's called
thinking duh i'm doing it right now
true
that's a really good point yeah we're
all allowed to think to ourselves i'm
saying verbalizing it is weird i'm sorry
but like i do find myself like thinking
in conversation version like talking to
myself still doesn't count okay so the
only time i think i've ever like spoken
to myself when i'm not around it's like
only like powering yourself up oh no i
mean yes before power poses that doesn't
because like unless i'm like let's say i
left my phone on this counter i come
over and i'm by myself i go to get my
phone off the counter and it's not there
i will say to myself like that's weird
yeah even if no one's around yeah yeah
i guess maybe
no i think i still think it's weird i
guess i talk to myself sometimes like
i'll just be around my room
breasts and stress and stress and stress
and strive some rats we have really
gotten out of control with theo's name
with bryson thrice you know what we
haven't done in a really long
dora the time
perfect angel dora crunchy delicious
dora bruno's cousin dora my one and only
dora special boy dora thick juicy dora
floppy ears dora what little nose dora
wagging tail dora sexy walk dora
dora
hey
theodora
[Music]
okay i'm sorry for those last few
minutes you guys it's safe to come back
now um what was the story
the queen had an intruder oh right
unacceptable like an embarrassment to
her security and the fact that this has
happened not once but twice is
disgraceful to the crown to the monarchy
and to all of england honestly i could
not do a british accent agreed do it
brother
graham no let me in gran let's just talk
i want to come to the party gran party
let's talk in british accents like i
find i can't do a british accent i can
only do
prince harry
i can't do like any accents maybe that's
why i'll never really make it as a
comedian that's so true because like
you can't do impersonations i can do uh
shakira but that's it that's not enough
no so like what would you do as like a
southern accent hey y'all
yeah how y'all doing hey brother that's
not southern hey bro could you do
australian yeah
hey brother
you're so [ __ ] annoying
i can do french hey bravo no you could
do french or brahma
you could do hebrew shalom
i don't know how to say hello to the
other languages
um
yeah that's a good point yeah
spanish hola brava
oh my god i just remembered something i
did i have to unburn it myself
i did
dude jackie i don't think i can say it
now you have to it is i'm literally
gonna cry oh my god
i did
this burden is coming from the depths of
her soul i did the most
embarrassing thing over the weekend like
i actually that's so funny because i
asked you on monday if you embarrassed
yourself this week oh my god i just
remembered i was really high like
really high
and
i mean i actually don't want to say it
i'm like so ashamed let it go
you have to set it down you have to um
you have to um
okay paint a picture so me and ben like
we got high at this party like on pot
and i got like a little like i don't
like being high in public like i really
don't so i was like can we please leave
and he was like yeah so we got in the
cab and when we got in bed i was like
feeling much better you know what i
started to enjoy like being high
and oh my my spray tan is literally
being cried off so we ordered food from
the diner and it was taking a long time
i can't say it like i literally can't
how could you have embarrassed yourself
so bad in your own house on the phone
oh god okay
[Music]
okay so i placed the order on the uh on
ubereats and then like a couple hours
later no hours sorry like 20 minutes
later we were like hi and we were like
where's the food so i called and i just
wanted to make sure like that the order
went through and the guy was really nice
he was like he was giving like big
italian like mobster over the phone he
was like yeah i got your order so i
don't know i like wanted to relate to
him
it's not what you think it's worse wait
i can't drink okay
so i when i was saying thank you he was
like so helpful and nice and i was like
high and dumb i couldn't even remember
what we were talking about so as we were
hanging out like wanted to relate to him
in some way like and like be like
authentic italian like
girly
that's you and i just i was just in
italy like a few months ago and i didn't
learn how to say anything except for
like good night
which is
something so as i'm hanging out with my
sir thank you so much
and he was like
he was like from new jersey like he
wasn't like italian
and he was like what
i was like bond week
he was like okay
[Music]
i was so embarrassed like
so many mary's like
why would
[Laughter]
i do feel better i do
i do feel better
i only have one thing to say
and to be honest i don't even think
that's how you say good night in italian
like i'm not sure
oh my god i can't breathe
i'm okay thank you for what are we
talking
oh my god you know what i really do feel
better like for real no that's important
yeah no but you were literally just like
talking to zack shapiro on the phone and
you said
yeah no he was literally not probably
not even italian right
oh my god i'm crying that's really funny
it's horrifying like beyond
but i'm okay and you feel better i do
thank you for letting me unburden myself
the power of the unburdening you guys
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story yeah which is a little
heartwarming sports news oh my god just
to take us home it's everything you guys
you have to watch a stick talk aaron
judge well it's a video that does reside
on tick tock as well as other platforms
no just to talk aaron judge homer leads
to fans wholesome moment so aaron judge
is a player for the new york yankees
tamara suddenly he's tamara's son and
he hit a home run congratulations mr
judge and a rival fan of the blue jays
caught it so the blue jays guy obviously
doesn't want
aaron judge's ball even though like if
you're like
into sports memorabilia like you could
sell the ball it's great to catch you
like well regardless even if you catch a
ball and it's not your team like you
usually keep it cause like it's cool
right but he was sitting next to this
little kid who was a big aaron judge fan
who's wearing the jersey and everything
and he gave it to the kid and the kids
they got it on camera the kid's life was
made and his dad's life was made and it
was just like this kid started crying
and gave like the biggest hug to this
random man from toronto and it's
literally so cute like it will bring a
tear to your eye and then they show like
the dad you know the sun going back to
the dad and the dad giving him the
biggest kiss like he was so proud of it
literally could bring tear in my eyes it
really could we'll post it on our tick
tock it is the on our tick tock on our
instagram it is the cutest most sweet
and like in a world that's so unwell
moments like these that's really why
like i don't like i don't really love
sports but i don't mind watching them
because like in sports there's always
something nice happening you know they
honor the military they help you know
people who are sick they're always doing
good things in sports and they're also
like they're representatives of their
community so they're always really doing
stuff for the community but sports do
bring people together they could also be
quite divisive yeah of course but i do
feel like at the end of the day
they bring more people together than
they then they separate people apart
they do more good than harm right
because people don't really get into
like real beef over rivalries but i
think for
a lot of people talking about sports
it's an immediate connection it's like
you know us talking about bravo right
right books all of a sudden we're best
friends that's true it's a family affair
it's bringing people together well thank
you for that gorgeous fifth and final
story that just really put a twinkle in
my eye you already had a tear in your
eyes i know i'm really not okay my
throat hurts from like laughing like
that um but the show's not over oh
really quickly okay let me do
okay let's dive into tv recap really
quick i know you didn't watch it so i
don't want to spoil anything for you
it's okay but i just wanted i've made a
choice you know and that doesn't mean i
can come here and ruin the show because
part one of the new jersey reunion is
just not what you would expect there's
so much drama on the left couch like
jennifer and dolores are not friends and
teresa had an engagement party and
didn't invite dolores so the left couch
is like crumbling um and actually
dolores said she said to the
to the other girl she said it to jackie
to melissa and margaret she's like i am
so sorry for defending jennifer all
these years like you were right i was
wrong
okay and what about teresa and teresa
was basically like you know we had an
engagement party with like all the
couples we go out with and dolores and i
you know we don't double date so and
doris was like if that's what theresa
wants it's fine
it's very cold oh okay fine like she's
not there's not uh they're not done but
like that couch is on their way to ruin
and that's why it was so upsetting
because i really felt like the
anti-theresa movement was making a lot
of progress last night like teresa
looked so stupid everything she said was
more dumb and dumb
by the minute and i was losing brain
cells
um and that's really to the credit of
marge and jackie and now that jackie's
been demoted like i just don't agree
with that decision whatsoever and i
actually saw a tweet that i
screenshotted because i thought it was
so profound
and it goes like this well anything can
happen they haven't started filming you
know maybe someone will hear these cries
and change course sources are confirming
that the rumors of jackie goldschneider
being made friend of for the next season
of rahunge
and somebody wrote my girl gave us the
rawest realest personal storyline across
the franchise in years and this is how
they repay her when dolores has been
renovating her house for five seasons
i'm sick from mark duffy i agree mark
wow
i just felt like finally we've actually
made progress in the dynamic of this
group where we all just like cow tower
theresa it's actually been like
frustrating to watch we are making
progress and i do feel like jackie
taking a step back
delineates that process yeah but we
still have marge and now dolores is
turning and melissa no but i think that
that tweet makes
an even better point than the fact that
we're making progress it's like she
literally just bared her soul and i
think helped a lot of people and it was
actually quite interesting for like
a viewer who hates for someone who hates
personal storylines like if in a
personal journey i hate that that
footage i couldn't get enough of
jackie's journey i thought it was beyond
interesting yeah and so and i think to
repay her in a demotion is so [ __ ] up
i agree completely so it ain't right um
but the melissa joe and teresa of it all
was super interesting like you know
teresa's
having a wedding she's having
bridesmaids and melissa's not one but
louie's sisters are so like her
sister-in-law's on the other side and
they had an engagement party and they
literally sat melissa joe and the kids
at like some random table in the back
with random people
and like
for so long so melissa doesn't get
involved and she doesn't defend her
friends because of teresa right and
theresa
and for for melissa that's like so big
she's she's sticking with the family and
the way that theresa has perceived it
all these years is that like melissa is
marge's friend and
she doesn't do anything for her it's not
enough that melissa doesn't
engage engage teresa expects her to back
her even though melissa thinks she's
wrong so it was so painful for melissa
and joe like just talking to this [ __ ]
who like she's like all right you know
okay joe you're always right like it
can't even
enter her brain that she is always wrong
like she's never been right about one
thing in her whole [ __ ] life she's
insufferable i don't understand how
people can stand this woman she's
awful and literally andy was like
you always say like melissa never
defends you like can you give us a
couple examples of times when you've
defended melissa and had melissa's back
and she's literally like oh
well you know guys help me like you know
you know like oh tell me like what and
then there was like a a freak circuit
breaker and the the lights went out
right right as she was like
and so they get the lights back on and
andy asked the question again and we got
it both times she's like you know like
guys come on help me out like it was
painful i cannot stand this woman like
it's
it's insane how invested i'm getting
it's so painful yeah no that's how i
feel after every time i watch new jersey
and then by the time we recap on the
show i feel like come to myself a little
bit but the the feelings are so visceral
yeah yeah
um so i want you to watch it and we'll
recap next week with part two okay um
with all the men because only joe gorga
came out not frank and then like not
frank no only joe gorga came out and
theresa was like you're such a little
[ __ ] boy like this is a housewives what
are you doing here her and jennifer
theresa and jennifer were ganging up on
joe like family family
and you're literally this girl you just
met last year you're hanging up on your
brother with her wait but if it's only
housewives then why is she doing
confessionals 100
but don't talk about chia don't you dare
talk about gia i don't want to um
so like if you're watching the season
like you know how painful it is and i'm
sorry that we're all going through this
together
now let's dive into your toasters which
is our advice segment if you ever want
to write in the email is dear toasters
gmail.com thank you to everyone who
resubmitted i told you guys like if it's
too long we really can't read it so a
lot of people resubmitted with shorter
more abridged versions and i'm extremely
grateful thank you
we also have an update today um but uh
dear toasters is brought to you by zip
recruiter if
zip recruiter is like if you own a
growing business and you need to hire
zip recruiter makes hiring so much
easier because they do the work for you
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
toast because certain people in life can
just make everything so much easier i
know a lot of you guys you know you lean
heavily on your co-workers personal
assistants whoever you work with
everyone is out here to help each other
and zip recruiters is helping you help
each other so zip recruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally ziprecruiter has a
complete suite of tools that make it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day it's no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one hired
number one rated hiring site based on g2
ratings as of january 1st 2022. the
hardest thing you have to do
when it comes to zip recruiter is
remembering our link and it's zip
recruiter
ziprecruiter.com
toast and that's not even hard that's
where you go to try ziprecruiter for
free once again that's zip
recruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t
zip recruiter.com slash toast thank you
zip recruiter for sponsoring your
toasters yes
sorry i had to burp i have got to stop
drinking lacroix during the show i need
to switch to flat water because i'm
always like uh
yeah are you ready yeah
hey jackson claude i'm in major need of
your vite of your advice because i'm
literally about to explode
my mother-in-law ooh
this is gonna be divisive my
mother-in-law has a terrible habit of
kissing my eight-month-old baby on the
mouth
you heard it on his freaking mouth i
verbalized it multiple times to friends
and family about how much it bothers me
and she has been there when i've
mentioned it it may not be a big deal to
others but to me it's just gross i
mentioned it to my p-jump husband and he
said he would address it with her but he
has yet to do so this weekend she did it
right in my husband's face when i tried
to get his attention to notice he
totally disregarded me he's a bit of a
mama's boy and he tends to feel bad
about hurting her feelings what bothers
me is that my mother-in-law works in
healthcare and can bring home whatever
she has seen at work and hello covid i
honestly wouldn't doubt if she was doing
it on purpose as we've had our issues in
the past and she tends to be
manipulative what do i do do i wait for
my husband to address it or should i
take it into my own hands and tell her
directly please help i promise to give
you an update sincerely a toaster who's
about to lose her [ __ ] okay i don't
think she's doing it on purpose to
bother you because i don't think she
would like she's not the baby's immune
system just to get at you there are
other ways i feel as though i have a
conflict of interest here you do because
you're the perpetrator i kiss harry on
the math but if you told me not to i
would never right you even said anything
so i'm going to keep i haven't really
seen it and that's what i would say
about this like i haven't if someone
were doing this you told me that you'd
do that but i never saw it if i saw it
and it didn't sit right with me i would
say it i would say it to anyone and i
would just say it on the spot and that's
the thing about being a mama that like
when something crosses your personal
line it doesn't matter if you're right
wrong it's how you feel that's your baby
you cooked pretend it's balanced you
pushed him out one way or the other
it's your way or the highway and so you
don't need to have your husband say
something if you see it stop it if it's
if it's not okay with you and it does it
makes you uncomfortable say please don't
do that especially follow my rules then
we're gonna have to set further
boundaries especially in this day and
age i feel like what we're always saying
like covet is the best excuse for
everything so like if you really want to
do soften the blow instead of just being
like even though i agree with your
approach like it's your baby [ __ ] off
but if you want to like soften the blow
a little bit you can like mention covid
you know like kobe is just giving us all
reasons to like
not do things we don't want to do
exactly and that's the small blessing
coming out of cobid so i agree if this
crosses your personal boundary like it's
enough just call it out call it when you
see it that's the best way to do stuff
don't let it faster yeah call it when
you see it i like that
i think that's been like one of the
biggest changes in me as a mama like
instead of you know usually are you
saying mama ironically i can't tell
like i know that it triggers you so
that's always fun but i do feel like
there's a difference between like being
a mom and being like a mama like a
you know and i think that that's
something for me where it's like used to
be
if something bothered me i would sit on
it think about it see if it still
bothered me and then find a way to deal
with it now it bothers me it's cut yeah
because mamas don't have time for that
so true
mama's ain't got the time so true
well i'm deferred on i defer to this
mama on that mama
next up hey girlies my three sisters mom
and i are all toasters and we need some
of your advice our younger brother 23 is
a pee job and he's never had a
girlfriend and we are 99 sure he was
still a virgin up until recently he's
been dating this 20 year old girl who
seems really immature her instagram is
in private so we were creeping and we
clicked on her bisco link in her bio the
first thing we see is an extremely
scandalous mirror pick of our brother
and her naked fresh out of the shower
she actually attached the picture to us
but i didn't want to see it because i
felt like it was invasive to make it
even more disco to make it even worse
this was taken to see it i need to see
it will you pull it up will you twist
the computer around
to make it even worse it was taken at
our parents house or you could email it
to me i have my ipad oh yeah email but
don't show it okay
but can you listen to me there's more
okay to make it even more assist was
taken at our parents house we are all
extremely disturbed and we just want to
protect our brother at all costs we are
meeting her for the first time this
weekend and we need your advice do we
say something to our brother do we wait
until after the weekend are we
overreacting thank you in advance and i
love you both so much i'm sorry but you
have the picture no not yet but
maybe she doesn't know that visco's
public
you can't say anything like he's living
his life
he's not doing anything you can see the
picture actually i need to see the
picture too the only thing you could say
like if there's
if it's really inappropriate you could
be like maybe you i shouldn't put the
poster somewhere
that's the only thing that they're doing
you know quote unquote right we have the
picture
oh
um it's not that bad honestly
let me see
it's [ __ ] weird honestly like
girl looks pretty
your brother looks hot
i like it i like it too it's a nice
photo it's very erotic did you send any
more screenshots i like the beat
no only the one i like the beat
listen your brother is an artist clearly
right even though what's so funny is
like
what's funny i don't know
what's funny about that is like it's
from visco and the picture appears to
have absolutely no filter yeah no it's
not about the visco um i don't know
how old is it that's just like really
crazy to see from your brother but again
like he's not doing anything wrong
knowing your brother looks cute like
there's no way he was a virgin sorry to
burst your bubble they're clearly very
into each other and i think that if you
say anything you're just going to drive
a wedge and maybe push him a little
further away so you've got to let this
thing run its course truckers for visco
nude pics honestly um
i'm like really i can't get a picture of
myself it's kind of stunning no have you
ever seen like a pose like that like i
have to do that with ben you know
that's perfect because we can't post
that picture i could post mine you could
post yours it was giving like
nicola in brooklyn it was giving like
annie leibowitz it was really stunning
honestly like i think you should just be
happy for your brother like the girl is
hot her boobs are amazing okay but here
let me throw two this way what would you
do if you saw that like snitch and the
new man were taking pictures like that
i would only be upset for her that it's
public because you know that things like
that can ruin your life and things like
that really shouldn't be that's gonna
ruin your life but you know if you're
job founded or something like it's
public it just would you wouldn't get
fired for something like that but it
would make people like look it's awkward
take it off the internet but like keep
taking pictures like that i like it send
direct terms
i like it but like if you're gonna say
something i would only be about the fact
that it's on public like [ __ ] like that
yeah is private yeah be like isn't this
a little private for the public
yeah depends how close you are and if
like you think that this was i'm gonna
like reverse google image search find
this girl's visco then her instagram and
befriend her yeah
she probably toast her
with tits like that she's gotta be totes
okay our final
submission is an update and it was an
update on one that i did with ben so i'm
gonna read you the submission okay
um my boyfriend of eight years and i
recently moved in together he's a p john
but moving in together sheds light on
habits that each other has that we're
not always been aware of and i think i
found his major flaw he's a booger
flicker they're everywhere don't get me
wrong everyone got to pick their nose
i'll do it sometimes but i always make
sure to use a tissue to make sure it's
hygienic but i'm finding this man's
boogers everywhere on walls dressers
blinds literally every day i swear i
find a booger in a place i least expect
it to the first one or two times i
pointed it out to him i called him gross
and we both laughed about it but now
it's reaching a disgusting level and i'm
not sure what to do he's my future
husband i love him to pieces what do i
do so here we wrote it we got an update
from her
and we told her well i i did that this
specific entry with ben because ben is
like always sneezing and his boogers fly
everywhere and he'll like leave him
crusted on the wall like it's disgusting
okay okay
so what'd you tell her to do break she's
got to be stern
because this habit doesn't die hard
clearly ben is working on it sounds like
he has like an overproduction of boogers
though you might have a sign his
infection
um hey hey ladies i wrote a few weeks
ago about my burger flicking and i'm
happy to report on some improvements i
loved ben's math of one booger
equalizing two seltzers oh because ben
was basically saying like ben if i'm
laying in bed like ben gets me a seltzer
he gets me out of like i don't get out
of bed and me wiping up his boogers is
the price i pay interesting so for every
two seltzers i get i have to clean up
one booger fair
so i loved ben's math of one booker
booger equaling two seltzers but
unfortunately i'm not weighted on hand
and foot by my boyfriend so i couldn't
really implement that advice into our
dynamic but someone in the toast
facebook group made a post about how
disgusting my dear toaster story was
embarrassing but understandable and
someone left a comment suggesting i keep
tissues around the house so they're
readily available when my boyfriend
feels like he needs to clear his nose i
don't know why i didn't realize that
before but it turns out the burger
flicking was just a result of pure
laziness since placing tissue boxes in a
few more places around the house i can
happily share that my walls and
furniture have been snot free ever since
and hopefully this habit will begin to
stick thank you ben the toasters for all
your help love a grateful toaster that's
such a great point i actually have
tissues all over my house you do like i
have one on each nightstand in the
bedroom we have one on our coffee table
in the living room we have one in the
bathroom like
we just do
it's crazy i don't have one box of
tissues at my house and no there it's
kind of like great to have no i agree
you think yeah i can use toilet paper
paper but you don't right and even if
you just have a little tickle you just
grab a tissue yeah
wow i'm learning so much yeah it's just
good for you too because now ben could
do it totally get him a box of tissues
on his side of the bed 100
100
um well so glad the toasters were able
to solve that for her even if we
couldn't and that's your toasters again
sometimes things are out of our control
agreed if you ever want to write in or
give an update for us on something
you've written in about it's dear
toasters gmail.com that is our show our
final show of the week the next time you
guys see me i will be a comedian who has
performed at madison square garden which
is just
so crazy and it's pretty cool
so that's our show any last words jacks
no we're so proud of you we love you
we're so excited i really feel like i'm
just going to be so overwhelmed with
pride and joy and i'm so looking forward
to seeing the show for the first time
for the first time just like a night out
seeing my favorite comedian in my
hometown what could be better and you're
going to be amazing so i look forward to
seeing you a different woman on monday
and you know what i have to say to
everyone
y'all have a great day everyone we'll
see you on monday and i'll see all you
guys tomorrow at madison square garden
bye
goodbye
[Music]
you